c'est bien monsieur casselman oui j'ai
l'honneur et le privilège de vous
annoncer que vous avez été choisi pour
recevoir le prix nobel de littérature
monsieur qu'un seul mode
bienvenue à stockholm nous sommes à
votre disposition monsieur cas seulement
dis moi que ceci n'est pas une énorme
blague non tout est vrai chéri
l'amc casselman qui a été contacté par
un éditeur pour faire un bouquin sur
youtube un écrivain doit écrire
s'il n'écrit pas son âme mourra de faim
j'ai lu les premiers livres que tu as
écrit c'est étrange à quel point son
style s'est améliorée après qu'il vous à
rentrer
on me dit que vous avez du talent
j'adore écrire c'est toute ma vie ne
soyez pas écrivain jamais vous ne
réussirez à attirer leur attention
je vous présente monsieur et madame
castle bac je m'appelle tune ma femme
est elle n'écrit pas
j'en ai ainsi dû autant j'en ai assez de
ces humiliations
je veux que tu me disent que je suis un
bon écrivain c'est le premier chef c'est
pas grave on peut pas rester ensemble de
nous deux c'est toi le petit prodige
je crois que vous êtes excédé d'être
invisible
moi j'en cette femme je ne suis personne
que faites vous dans la vie madame
casselman
je suis faisait de rois mages été
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce que nous faisons est absolument rien
de honteux
je vais vous raconter toute l'histoire
[Musique]